[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission avec mon
invité Jean h bonjour bonjour vous venez
pour un livre que vous venez de faire
paraître aux éditions l'Harmattan la
médecine personnalisée une promesse à
interroger alors on va avant d'entrer
dans le cœur du livre on va parler un
petit peu de vous d'abord
ça peut-être vous êtes un élu de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux absolument depuis
quelques années
mais vous êtes surtout un physicien vous
êtes spécialiste des biotechnologies des
créateurs d'ailleurs du Généthon
du premier Généthon qui avait sa vie
pour les le génome humain pour le génome
absolument parler
des chiffrages du jet d'eau humain vous
êtes spécialiste des thérapies
génétiques géniques pardon et puis
après cette carrière scientifique vous
avez passionné vous étiez sur une
passionné déjà pour la philosophie vous
avez soutenu une thèse de philosophie
qui s'appelle vers la prévention et
l'anticipation de la pratique médicale
réflexion sur l'épistémologie des
biomarqueurs dans le cas de la maladie
d'Alzheimer je cite tout le titre de la
thèse non pas que voilà c'est quand même
pour des spécistes et c'est de la
philosophie c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle c'est de la philosophie des
sciences épistémologie c'est ça la
critique des philosophiques des sciences
je dis ça parce que cette thèse ou ce
livre plutôt c'est un peu le la
continuation d'une certaine façon de
cette thèse vous êtes intéressé
d'Alzheimer dans dans la thèse là vous
étendez aussi elle m'avait dit
l'Alzheimer aussi au cancer
ce que c'est la médecine personnalisée
sur ces plans là donc c'est ça c'est une
continuation de votre travail au fond
oui oui c'est une extension en fait
sachant qu'elles aimer c'est un type de
maladie et les maladies sont beaucoup
plus nombreuses et beaucoup plus
différentes et il ne pose pas les mêmes
questions
d'où ma comparaison si vous voulez les
cancers comme la maladie d'Alzheimer mon
sa vie un peu de comparatif d'accord
alors avant d'entrer dans la
problématique de ce faisait dans le
livre
qui vous a passionné justement dans ce
questionnement de de la médecine
il s'agissant de domaine scientifique
qu'est-ce que la philosophie que nous
apporter là-dessus ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
amené en fait en même temps mes
réflexions c'est que j'ai ressenti une
tension entre une approche purement
scientifique de la médecine et une
approche beaucoup plus globale de nature
un peu plus philosophique de ce fait
prenant la personne dans son dans son
entier et dans sa globalité c'est cette
tension je mon analyse si vous voulez ça
a été que réduire la le passion à ces
données scientifiques ne suffit pas la
personne est un être complexe social
situé et c'est ça que j'ai voulu
analyser cette tension c'est ça
c'est-à-dire que oui on pourrait avoir
tendance cet homme médecin est aux
scientifique à nous considérer que les
données scientifiques ça ne suffit
peut-être pas je précise vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs je suis pas médecin
tous les gens
réagissaient sur le sur le sur le covid
et
en disant je ne suis pas médecin mais
c'était tous les jours
philosophique de ça
alors il faut déjà interroger les mots à
la médecine la médecine on a tendance à
considérer c'est de la tradition que bah
c'est fait pour soigner les maladies
c'est curatif mais aujourd'hui il y a
d'autres médecines il y a la médecine il
y a la prévention
absolument la prédiction absolument
alors
expliquez-nous peut-être parce que ça
c'est très important si vous voulez
alors d'abord les techniques ont permis
l'acquisition d'un donc très important
de donner et ces données évidemment faut
l'objet de ta d'analyses statistiques et
autres et on met en évidence que les uns
les autres ont des ce qu'on a
caractérisé comme facteur de risque par
exemple pour des facteurs de risque
c'est certaines maladies qui sont des
facteurs de risque c'était pas des c'est
pas des certitudes c'est basé sur des
corrélations sur des analyses
statistiques mais l'analyse du génome
fait que chacun est porteur de mutation
particulière et que ces mutations
peuvent donner des propriétés plus
importantes d'être atteint d'un cancer
d'être un tas d'une maladie de
neurodégénérative etc et justement alors
est-ce que les les progrès de la
génétique et notamment le le
séquencement du génome fait que
maintenant on sait
sur l'homme alors moi moi je on connaît
le génome c'est vrai mais on sait
finalement très peu de choses parce
qu'il faut bien se rendre compte que le
gène le génome c'est une information
statique on a notre génome dans toute
cellules on a le même génome mais ce
génome ne s'exprime pas de la même façon
dans toutes les circonstances et voyez
et il y a donc une différence entre
l'information génétique qui est statique
et la façon dont elle s'exprime qui
dynamique et cette expression dépend de
du mode de vie dépend de l'environnement
dans lequel se situe dépend des
accidents auxquels on peut être soumis
etc vous voyez que c'est pas parce que
nous dit pas on est condamné forcément
absolument pas du tout narrative pas du
tout pas du tout il y a d'autres
influences absolument parce que les
gènes que l'on a
on peut maîtriser ou ne pas maîtriser
parce que c'est pas aussi simple que ça
son expression or c'est l'expression
de certains gènes qui peut créer des
maladies mais si on évite l'expression
de ces gènes évidemment on se protège
d'où la prévention quand même d'où la
prévention absolument on peut aussi
prévenir
je profite pour faire une remarque quand
même vous savez que le génome est
aujourd'hui facile à ses concis c'est
facile et ça coûte pas cher
1000 dollars on peut avoir et si vous
voulez il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
envoient un peu de salive des sociétés
aux États-Unis voilà récupère les
limitations mais le problème c'est que
ça n'est pas interprété c'est des
données brutes et à mon avis c'est un
peu dangereux pour les personnes ah oui
d'accord oui parce que après il faut de
l'auto
on va vous dire vous avez x % de d'avoir
le diabète résultat vous disent j'ai le
diabète
aussi vous voyez l'exemple cholestérol
par exemple c'est assez intéressant les
gens qui ont du cholestérol considère
qu'ils ont ils sont pas malades
parce que justement dans la conclusion
vous êtes assez modéré sur peut-être les
progrès de la médecine mais on va en
parler il y a quand même vous parler un
chapitre vous assistez aussi beaucoup
sur le mot savoir parce que c'est
important de le savoir sur l'homme le
savoir ce qu'on sait et et on se
souvient évidemment Foucault avait fait
le lien entre le savoir et le pouvoir et
on se rend compte qu'au fond les les
investisseurs les gens qui investissent
le plus dans le dans le milieu de la
santé et de la médecine ce sont les
patrons des gafams ce sont les
milliardaires des gars femme
est-ce que est-ce que c'est une façon
pour eux à votre avis d'avoir le pouvoir
je sais pas mais enfin j'ai pas la
réponse vraiment à cette question
délicate d'ailleurs mais mais
effectivement
il faut se rendre compte aussi que dans
le domaine de la médecine c'est un
domaine où jackpot en quelque sorte
c'est-à-dire il y a beaucoup de risques
de ne jamais aboutir mais si on aboutit
on gagne les voilà et et les gens qui
sont dans les gafam et autres c'est un
peu leur plaisir de de faire des paris
ils ont des moyens de les faire mais ils
aiment bien les faire
absolument alors parlons aussi du mot
médecine mais médecine personnalisée
alors ben c'est une personnalisée on se
dit bah au fond c'est ce qu'on appelle
le colloque singulier entre le patient
oui et le médecin c'est déjà ça mais
vous dites ça va plus loin que ça c'est
autre chose si ça va plus loin que ça
parce que dans le mot personnalisation
il y a le dialogue médecin patient ça
c'est vrai dire que singulier mais il y
a aussi le souci de
pour finir les traitements adaptés à la
personne en fonction de ces données
personnelles de ces modes de vie de ces
données génétique de ces données
physiologiques vous voyez donc le le mot
là c'est vrai que le mot personnalisé
nécessite de ce que c'est qu'une
personne et une personne c'est quelqu'un
de singulier très différent on est tous
différents les uns des autres mais qui
est aussi un être social dans un
environnement et tout cet environnement
doit être prise en compte dans la façon
de traiter une maladie mais vous dites
aussi que la médecine personnalisée
c'est aussi je cite une médecine
stratifiée qui subdivise la population
en sous-groupe alors ça c'est disons à
la définition de départ de la médecine
personnalisée parce qu'au départ la
médecine personnalisée c'était pas quand
je l'individu l'individu c'était de
classer les individus en soucoupe de
plus en plus étroit de façon à définir
des traitements qui soient pas
universels mais qui soit adapté à une
de la population et c'est à la
stratification c'est classer les
individus en fonction de leur donner
génétique dans des tranches et la
médecine personnalisée c'est pas tout à
fait la médecine individualisée non non
justement
voilà
c'est l'individu et c'est là justement
il y a le mot personnalisé est très
polycémique en fait et dans la pratique
les gens pensent que c'est adapté à la
personne
dans la pratique c'est simplement cibler
sur une classe de personnes qui ont les
mêmes caractéristiques mais ça peut
avoir son intérêt d'ailleurs beaucoup de
ça beaucoup d'intégrer
l'exemple très connu sur le cancer du
sein par exemple le fameux sceptible de
roche
inadapté ni intéressant que pour
certaines personnes que certaines femmes
qui ont un certain gène qui permet de
quelque chose alors vous penchez sur
donc deux types de maladies je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure un petit peu
les cancers et puis le dit des
générative notamment l'Alzheimer
pourquoi pourquoi ce choix là alors
pourquoi parce que d'abord je pense que
l'important c'est quand même les
maladies longue durée d'accord les
maladies chroniques la durée c'est pas
les maladies évidemment
donc c'est ça et et et et et je pense
que la génétique a fait beaucoup de
progrès sur les cancers absolument et
ces progrès sur les cancers ont conduit
à des terres à des thérapies vraiment
adaptés
au concert d'un individu donc c'est
d'ailleurs dans les tout ce qu'on entend
parler dedans quand on parle de médecine
personnalisée très souvent réduit ça au
traitement contre les cancers d'accord
bon ça c'est le deuxième point à la
verse il y a des maladies type les
maladies neurodégénératives qui sont
aussi des maladies évolutives sur des
traitements longue durée et pour lequel
le
l'explication par le génome par les
gènes n'est pas du tout au point
d'accord peut-être que ça viendra il y a
des dates mais pour l'instant on peut
pas dire vous avez le gène qui fait que
vous avez la sensibilité forte atteindre
Alzheimer d'avoir une maison voilà on
sait pas c'est une famille de maladies
et évolutive aussi qui perturbent
beaucoup les individus leur famille de
même qu'un cancer donc c'est pour ça
c'est se distingo j'ai pris ces deux
maladies neurogatives et cancer comme
des exemples de thérapie d'un côté parce
que le cancer est très étudié partout et
de l'autre côté parce que Alzheimer est
une maladie qui est très étudiée aussi
mais pour lequel le niveau de
connaissance est beaucoup plus faible
quelques conclusion générale vous tirez
de votre de ce travail que vous faites
ma conclusion générale enfin c'est que
sans nier parce que de s'ennuyer
l'apport des techniques des équipements
des Big Data des traitements
informatiques etc qui conduisent à des
projets des progrès très importants au
point de vue des traitements et de la et
des médecins
la conclusion que je retire c'est qu'il
faut éviter de n'allez que versa
d'accord et qu'il faut prendre la
personne dans sa globalité qu'il faut
écouter la personne la façon dont elle
exprime ce qu'elle ressort dans sa
maladie etc et il faut l'accompagner et
c'est pour ça que je je je fais bien la
complémentarité entre le soin
le cuivre et le trait et le prendre soin
et le promoteur parce que en plus ce que
je conseille la sélection les progrès de
par exemple contre les concerts il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens qui
guérissent du cancer mais les gens
considèrent que après avoir grillé et
redeviennent comme il était avant or ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai et
c'est là où l'accompagnement et le
prendre soit même après la maladie ou
même en face de rémission est très
important est-ce que vous êtes de ceux
qui pensent comme beaucoup qu'on est
quand même un stade où il va y avoir des
immenses progrès de la médecine et que
qui vont aboutir sur un allongement de
la vie assez considérable moi je pense
effectivement qu'on alors considérable
non je crois pas à quoi faire ça des
fois ça dépend
moi j'y crois pas en tout cas si on y
arrive
bien sûr bien sûr mais mais j'y crois
pas est-ce que vous dites
est pas certain quoi moi je pense que si
vous voulez le vieillissement il est
réel notre espérance de vie elle est
plus importante que ceux de nos parents
c'est clair bon mais mais
l'allongement de vie n'a de sens que si
on vit
bien oui mais c'est ce que
c'est content l'objectif 150 ans n'a pas
beaucoup de sens en soi effectivement
dire alors c'est vrai qu'on a parlé de
médecine curative mais c'est une
préventive mais il y a aussi
régénérative absolument qui arrive
aujourd'hui bien sûr quel est votre
position sur le transhumanisme monsieur
l'homme augmenté sur
alors le moment monter pour moi c'est un
peu différent d'hydroshumanisme d'accord
le mot monté effectivement c'est c'est
une façon de compenser ses propres
organes par des organes artificiels qui
permettent de rester bien le
transhumanisme c'est différent enfin
c'est un peu c'est aller plus loin c'est
considéré que nous nous sommes des des
hommes et biologiques des hommes
biologiques avec accord etc dépasser la
biologie et que et que l'on va pouvoir
définir un homme nouveau entre
guillemets qui qui sera d'ailleurs
probablement déconnecté de son corps
alors après après évidemment est-ce
qu'on va se contenter du cerveau de
l'individu il aura plus de corps etc ou
est-ce que on aura un corps artificiel
fera comme si je ne sais pas mais je
pense que c'est quand même quelque chose
à surveiller mais à surveiller mais ne
pas considérer comme c'est une évolution
obligatoire c'est ce que dit en
conclusion qu'on aura peut-être des
surprises
en tout cas c'est un domaine absolument
tout peut changer
merci infiniment je rappelle le titre de
votre livre la médecine personnalisée
une promesse à interrogée et c'est aux
éditions merci beaucoup je vous remercie
[Musique]